Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're taking a look at Telepresence,
a tool for helping
Kubernetes development, which has been notoriously difficult over
the years.
Now before we get started, I just wanna
start with a little bit of housekeeping. First,
if you've not subscribed to the YouTube channel,
shame on you. Please do that now and
click the bell so that you get notifications
for all future episodes.
Also, if you like to chat, talk cloud
native and Kubernetes, there is a Discord server
where you can come and join. We are
around 400 people now talking about all things
tech all the time. Really good fun. Come
and say hello.
And, of course, lastly, I wanna thank Equinix
Metal. They are my employer, but they also
allow me to produce this show on their
time, helping us all learn cloud native together.
So thank you Equinix Merrill. You can use
a code Rawkode. This will get you two
hundred hours of credits to test on our
platform. That's roughly four hundred hours of compute
if you use a modest instance, but you're
gonna have much more fun using it with
the bigger instances.
So, you know, use it as you wish.
And today, we're taking a look at Telepresence.
Sorry. I caught a comment out of the
corner of my eye. I'll answer that in
a minute. No.
Today, I'm joined by Daniel and Peter.
Hello.
Hello, everyone. Hey, David. Yeah. Sorry. I I
don't often get caught by comments but it
just popped right up and it was just
Noel asking do I have new headphones.
Very
good thing to know. Yes. I do. My
wife was moaning at me because my last
headphones were noise cancelling and I would talk
too loud so these are open ears so
that I can maintain my volume. Anyway Brilliant.
Random segue.
So thank you for joining me today, Daniel
and Peter. Do just wanna just take a
little bit of time and tell us who
you are, what you do? We'll start with
you, Daniel, there. Yeah. Hi, everyone. Thanks for
the intro, David. Thanks for inviting us along.
So my name is Daniel Bryan, director of
DevRel Ambassador Labs.
My background actually started in academia, but then
moved into Java development. I say my native
language is Java,
then a whole bunch of JavaScript and other
things along the way.
Reluctant operator is what I like to say
to myself. Right? I was always the build
person. Like, I I naturally gravitated towards Hudson
and then Jenkins as it changed,
and then kinda just followed that through my
consulting career in London, doing a lot of
work with Mesos.
And then, of course, when Kubernetes came on,
like, initially betting on Mesos, then suddenly I
realized, hang on. Kubernetes is where it's at.
Right? And then I've got friendly with the
Vasa Labs folks or Data Wires, we were
called back then. And Telepresence,
the first version of it,
was just popping up. And and for me,
it solved a real problem. And that's actually
when I joined the company. I was like,
this Telepresence tool and then the Ambassador API
Gateway, super useful for what I'm doing. You
know, I like these people. I should work
with them. And that's what I did.
Peter, over to you.
Cool. Thanks, Daniel. Yeah. So Peter O'Neil, developer
advocate at Ambassador Labs.
I kinda got my start in network engineering,
moved more into dev ops space, did a
little bit more coding stuff,
came across DevRel about a year ago, and
then moved over to Ambassador Labs about six
months ago where I've kind of been, leading
the charge on on talking about Telepresence and
teaching Telepresence, kind of, like, getting it into
the hands of as many people as possible.
And so yeah. So I've been having a
great time kinda kinda kinda playing with the
tech. So great to be here, David. Mhmm.
Awesome. We have a Java developer and a
network engineer. Awesome.
It's a nice It's like a big of
a joke. Right? Well,
yeah, definitely could be. Walked into a bar.
Yeah.
Yeah. No. I'm not gonna try and make
up a joke. I'm not that smart. Right.
How is Java in the cloud native landscape
these days? Is it better? Because it it
used to be quite a challenge.
Yeah. I mean, funny. Richard, like, boss and
I were just talking to everyone today. You
know, the advent of Spring Boot in particular
changed a lot of stuff. So hats it
to the Spring community.
The the Java community and everyone sort of
picked up from them. There's Microprofile.
There's Quarkus from the Red Hat team. There's
lots of interesting web frameworks in the space
now that have baked in cloud libraries, cloud
primitives. So I'm playing around a lot on
my free time quite a bit with Quarkus.
It's super interesting. You can do native builds,
for example.
So, like, a lot of problems you have
with the big JVM of kind of you
know, you can address them now and run
small footprint stuff. That's awesome. Yeah. I was
always really excited
by GraalVM. I thought that was really exciting.
That's it. Yes.
Yeah. And Scala, I think they just last
week, they released version three of that language,
and I always really liked writing Scala, but
running the JVM and containers
just got really cumbersome. So maybe that's something
I can start experimenting
with more now. That's cool.
Right. Here, that's our segue done. Let's get
let's get back on track. We're gonna talk
Telepresence today. So I believe, Daniel, you're gonna
give us a little bit of a quick
introduction, and then we're gonna get straight into
our hands on section.
Yeah. Sure thing. Let me just set us
up here with the share screen.
There you go. You're up. Looking good.
So I'm sure anyone who's a coder will
recognize this. You get the inner and outer
dev loops. Now the massive hat tip to
Mitch Denny, where I got the initial idea
from. Unfortunately, the the blog post has disappeared
now. It's a four zero four. So I've
managed to find the graphic from someone else
who's saw this as well. But you'll recognize
that if you're doing TDD, you get that
inner loop. Right? You come up with a
test. You write some code. You verify it,
and you go go around and and, you
know, you're often working locally here. Even if
you're not doing TDD, you come up with
an idea. You code some stuff. You, you
know, put your print line in. You see
what's going on.
When you're happy, then you go to the
outer loop. You typically, you know, commit to
git, commit to, you know, version control. You
might run some integrations, some testing, and then
you release ultimately and and so forth. Now
the challenge we've seen oh, I'm challenge we've
seen with Kubernetes is once you get to
a certain point,
if you the in and out loop are
quite similar. You're writing code,
then you're building a container, you're pushing to
registry, deploying to cluster just to test,
and this can be quite slow. You know,
you wanna stay local as long as you
can, You wanna mock things, but, of course,
when you're running, like, say, mocks, stubs, doubles,
there's a whole bunch of assumptions
in there. Right? So sometimes you just you're
in that small little inner loop, but you
really wanna test what you're doing against some
dependency.
And you really wanna avoid that docker build,
let alone the docker push, like, to a
remote registry. Right? And it's something that Peter
and I play around with a lot is
you actually wanna be using your own tools
locally.
So, you know, much as you might have
some services running on a remote Kubernetes cluster,
some, you know, locally,
you wanna be connecting them all up but
using the local tools.
You know, I'm sure many of us know
about remote debugging, you know, ports and, you
know, Kubernetes cluster or just their VM in
general. But, you know, swapping between local then
remote, local and remote is all a bit
of a hassle.
When you're starting out, a lot of folks
do just code literally everything locally. Right? Pick
your poison, Docker, minikube, branch, or micro kits,
k three s.
But and this comes from my Java days.
Once you get past a certain number of
services,
your laptop, even, you know, even a nice
max 16 inch here will not keep up.
Right? Like, you you just you get that
point where you have to expand into remote
cluster. You know, you can't run all your
services locally.
And that's where Telepresence
really helps.
A bunch of different sort of phrases I've
heard around Telepresence is fancy Kubernetes VPN for
development. It's something I hear quite a bit.
Kube couple port forward on steroids. Hear that
one quite a bit. And if anyone knows
that Kube couple port forward, like the syntax,
I always have to Google it because it's
quite tricky to remember. Right? And and you're
doing one pod at a time, whereas Telepresence
kinda makes that much, much easier. So that's
why they're on steroids.
But fundamentally, it's a network bridge between your
laptop and the Kubernetes cluster. So I mentioned
a few times there that kind of scenario
where you got local services and remote services.
Telepresence is that bridge. So we can do
stuff locally without Docker build, without Docker push.
We can use our IDE, use our tools
locally
as if we were in the cluster. The
local services we got running are bridged effectively
in terms of network namespace
with the remote cluster.
And if this seems a bit sort of
hand wavy at the moment, the demo that
David is gonna look through and and Peter
should make this all super clear. Telepresence is
one of those tools and you see it,
you're like, oh, yeah. Totally get it. You
try it, and then often you really, how
do I do development without it? You often
think. Right? So that's the kind of setup
I wanted to do, if that's alright, sir.
Perfect. David, I'll stop sharing.
Alright. Thank you for that. So
let's ask you the the
the difficult question, easy question. Oh, we'll see.
Like, the the picture with the laptop on
fire. Right? I think this is a problem
that is now ubiquitous when I speak to
people that are trying to work out how
to get their development workflow working in a
Kubernetes environment.
And there's a certain pain threshold, if you
will, that at x number of services, it
just doesn't become physically possible anymore to run
all that stuff locally. You do need to
revert back to like the shared dev server
of 19 whatever 90.
Yep. So
if we invert that a little bit,
does it make sense and would you encourage
that everybody starts to look at Telepresence now
regardless of the number of services with that
pain with that pain point there,
or do you think that there's a certain
point where then you start to look at
Telepresence? Like, does that make sense?
It does. Peter, do you wanna have a
go at that one? Oliver Oliver think. Yeah.
Definitely. And so so
what it really comes down to is building
out a consistent development workflow. Right? And so
so if you are a team of one,
it it may seem like a bit of
overkill because you're like, oh, I can do
all this stuff now. But and so then
when you change the process later, then you
have that that that that change tax where
all of a sudden it's like, oh, now
you're trying to introduce something new. So if
you can actually introduce Telepresence when it is
only one service and one person, right, and
then you add two or three more people
onto the team, all of a sudden now
you have this process that scales
very well as the team grows with you.
So so so, yes, like, you you can
adopt it very early and and but I
think it scales very well if you do.
Awesome. That's exactly the answer I was hoping
to hear because I think that
you're building these really good development practices early
is really important. And I'll go back to
something Daniel said in the slides as well
is that
doubles and mocking
are never really good enough. Right? And especially
if you're using cloud,
you know, provided services like s three or
RDS, etcetera. You know, we do have tools
like local stack that try to provide enough
of an API that your application's gonna work,
but why not just use those actual services
and actually have guarantees in the way that
it's gonna work? And I think those approaches
definitely work better for most situations.
I would add that's great point there. And
I would add, like I've got a hat
to it always on on every chat, really.
Cindy work,
copy construct. I'm sure you bumped into her
fantastic writings. And she talks a lot about
fidelity. Right? It's the amount of fidelity you
want. Like, there's the testing against, like, mocks,
which gives you you know, it's quick, but
it gives you limited confidence.
Then you can fire up, say, local stack.
It gives you a bit more confidence because
it's, you know, an emulation of those
data stores. But then if you actually push
into, like, the the real thing, well, the
fidelity is super high there. Right? But it
can be typically a bit slower. So I
think for me, it's let's see if anyone
hasn't read Cindy's work. You know, after the
stream, Google copy construct. She's on Twitter. She's
on medium. Like, some fantastic blog posts that
talk about the trade offs around fidelity when
testing.
Yeah. And generally just all around awesome writing
under a Sherpa system. Yeah. Find just go
read everything on the blog. Yeah. Basically.
Alright. Well, awesome. I'm really excited to start
playing with Telepresence.
So let's get my screen shared and we're
gonna start from
nothing. We're gonna see how we can start
to use this for our development workflow.
So let's see. We have three floating heads.
I have the Telepresence documentation,
and I have a terminal.
It's all I need. Right? We happy? Looks
good. Looks good. Looks good to me. Yep.
Alright. Awesome. So
let's see. I'm assuming I'm gonna have to
just install the Telepresence binary to my machine.
Yep. Yep.
Just do Yeah. You could just go all
in whole block if you want. Yeah.
Yeah. We could go all in on the
quick start, David, and it literally downloads and
does everything for you. Depends how manual you
wanna go. Oh, I skipped the page. Yeah.
If you go new to Kubernetes on the
left there,
like, it'll literally
provision your cluster up in our cloud
and also give you a package to download,
and it will then download Telepresence
everything for you.
Okay. So let's see.
Sign in to ambassador cloud. Let's do that.
Did you wanna give us the
the pitch on ambassador cloud while I just
quickly sign up?
Yeah. Sure thing. So I'll have them oh,
go for it. Go for it, Peter. Sorry.
Yeah. So so I'll say Ambassador Cloud is
is something that we've relatively recently added, and
it connects our open source tools under kind
of one umbrella and allows you to to
to have, like, one central place. For, like,
Telepresence, we have the idea of what is
an intercept, which which does the connection.
And so Ambassador Cloud can hold those for
you. And, like, you can see a list
of not just yours, but if you are
associated with the team, you can see intercepts
for for the rest of your team as
well. And then that allows you to share
and collaborate very easily.
Okay. So it has downloaded something.
You have to unzip it.
Maybe should be good to go.
Alright. I have a cube config
and an install fail.
I was gonna be very trusting there, but
you know, maybe I'll just get it at
least.
Yeah.
I've curled it and picked it to bash
just fine. But the fact that I downloaded
it, no. I gotta be careful. Alright. I
like the way you completely skipped over the
read me as well. Love it.
Read
me's what? What are those?
Okay. So several dependencies.
Oh, okay. Let's do something.
So should I have read the read me?
Was that was I being very That's up
to you. Peter and I spent like hours
crafting the perfect weaving. We're not offended though.
Right?
Alright. Okay. Let's read that.
Actually, it has to the team. I don't
think it was us that wrote it, Peter,
was it?
I don't think so. I think I think
we might have commented on it, though. Yeah.
It's our amazing engineering team that have done
a lot of the heavy lifting here.
Yeah. I I always really appreciate it when
companies provide these kind of just one push
button deploys to give me something to actually
play with it, test with it with. So
it's really cool and that I was able
to do that. And I didn't have to
enter a credit card which is always a
major plus one.
So
we've installed
this is telling me I now have access
to Telepresence.
We have some demo applications. It looks like
we've got something in node.
We've got something in flask slash Python.
Fast API is that Python too? Is that
something else? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Java and go. Where's the rust? Where's the
rust love?
And
I can reuse install to trigger any of
it. Okay. Nice.
Let's just make sure
I have the Telepresence CLI.
That was nice and easy to get started.
Now I just jump back over to here
and
okay. So now let's test that cube control.
The chat people know me so well. No
rust. Rawkode will be sad.
Thanks, Nuno.
Now your audience. Good stuff. Yeah.
Let's export our cube config.
What was it called? Dot YAML.
Wait. I already had one here locally. That
could have been awkward. At least it would
get.
And run.
Let's see.
Looks good.
So the I just wanna make sure I
got this right. This is
provided to me via ambassador cloud.
It's just a Kubernetes API.
I don't know if oh, yeah. KCS, I
can see it there in a version. And
and this is just mine. I can use
this. Does this disappear? Does it run for
a certain amount of time? Can you maybe
help me understand
the magic a little bit?
Yeah. With the so so with the with
the quick start, this spins up
kind of your access to one of our
demo clusters. And the demo cluster,
we I think we we've changed the lifespan
of them a couple times, but right now,
believe it lasts a couple of days. I
have to I I don't remember exactly, but
but, like, I think you have a couple
days of of where you can log in
and use it. But then once it disappears,
you can just start it up again and
get a get a brand new demo cluster.
So is this namespace exclusive to me, or
am I sharing this with anyone else that
just happened to kinda be using it at
the same time?
No. No. The whole cluster should be yours.
Like, it's one virtual Kubernetes cluster.
So that whole thing is yours.
Awesome. Cool. And we do watch for bit
more coin mining. If anyone's thinking of jumping
in. Right?
I wasn't gonna make that joke. It didn't
cross my mind. I thought, no. Let's not
put people ideas in people's heads because these
they don't need anymore.
But you're right. You were straight in there.
I don't know. Were you susceptible to any
of the pull request spam over the last
few months with crypto miners and open source
projects? I know that we got hit by
a fair bit on Tinkerbell and other projects.
But like, you know No. That's CircleCI and
and and that gets out for example. Right?
Sort of, know, big name casualties there. But
no. We do monitor our our sort of
stack pretty pretty aggressively.
Yeah. That's
perfectly understandable.
Alright.
Okay. We run get services. I can see
these are running. So we've got our Kubernetes
one, which is just API. We've got some
other services running.
So it's not asking me to run a
Telepresence
status.
Mhmm. That raises questions.
So
as Telepresence
using my kubectl context to understand if I
already have something running, or am I making
too many guesses?
Yes. So so with that
Telepresence
has parts. Right? Because Telepresence is is bridging
your local laptop with your remote cluster. Right?
And it's creating
what is kind of like a VPN, but
it's more so bridging your local network with
that remote network. So there's two two pieces,
like one on each end. Right? You have
your Telepresence,
binary locally on your machine, which runs that
local daemon, and then you have the what
is called a traffic manager running in the
cluster. And those are the two pieces that
create the bridge that allows you to access
the network resources in the cluster.
Okay. So these ambassador
pods, are these what are
fulfilling that duty?
No. No. I think it's not running yet.
Once you actually
when the next steps when we actually connect,
Telepresence is going to do a scan for
for those services. And when it doesn't see
them, it will spin them up. Right. Okay.
Yeah. That makes sense.
And so here we here we we are
asking for the password because because we are
starting that local daemon, that is a suited
process.
Yeah. I've made so many mistakes typing my
password in that I'm just gonna run off
screen.
Open up your notepad with all your passwords
and you're Here we go.
I don't know. It happened to me like
it was with Alex Ellis. I don't know
if you're familiar but we we did the
stream together like four months ago or something.
And the actual shell
of the pseudo process segfalse
which I've never seen before ever
as I was halfway through typing my password
and it was all on the screen. Oh.
So now I'm just always that little bit
extra careful. Even though it's just my laptop
password, there's there's still I'll I'll take precautions.
Okay.
I'm really glad I ran get pods all
before just out of sheer luck I guess.
Now we've ran Telepresence
Connect. So what I suggest or what I
think is we're gonna see
nothing different.
Oh no. Do we? Yeah. Very last one.
The very last one. Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. I missed that. Okay.
So that's just running the traffic manager, enter
cluster. I'm assuming I'm sure I could read
the docs and it's gonna tell me what
to do, but I like to assume
yeah. There we go.
We now have
bets connected stuff
to do even though I don't know what
that stuff is here.
Awesome.
So,
that's
interesting.
The magic just keeps coming. So
I can just curl
and hit my cluster?
Yes. So so so this is this is
the networking that I was previously
speaking about where now your local laptop has
a direct network connection into your cluster. So
your DNS resolution in the cluster is now
available on your local machine, and that Kubernetes
service in the default namespace is now reachable
through the Kubernetes API.
Mhmm.
Fancy.
Alright.
I've got a few
maybe two questions.
So
if I am switching
kubectl context regularly,
will that be a problem for Telepresence?
So so right now, Telepresence,
it it
if you start it up and you switch
context, it will it will air out because
it'll say, oh, context has changed. And remember,
the Telepresence binary on your machine is essentially
creating a tunnel to one cluster.
So right now, that is that is a
limitation where you'd want to quit out of
one connection before you started up a new
connection with another cluster.
But but it is something that we are
aware of, and because
I feel like no one has just one
cluster nowadays. Right? So so so it is
something that that that we we we have
a we have a note to to see
if we can make that switching a little
more seamless.
Alright. Okay. So is there a
like,
did I run Telepresence disconnect when I was
changing cluster? Is that a command? Am I
We have we have Telepresence quit. Quit. Or
Telepresence uninstall,
which will actually remove the the will tear
down the the pieces that create the connection.
Okay. Telepresence
quit says there's something I would type after.
I've got my unit test failing and I'm
giving up for the day. So maybe maybe
I think I'll enjoy that after a bit
more time. Okay.
So that's I mean, right off the bat,
that's just interesting.
Querying the
an actual service within my cluster locally. That's
pretty cool. I really like that.
That is a while straight away, David. Right?
In terms of like it's even more impressive
when like you're hitting a like I said,
an application, which we'll do in a minute,
I think, in in the getting started. Right?
But I remember when I first up, this
is kinda cool. Right? Before I'd have to
look for the pod name, do a koo
kettle port forward,
hit that, you know, all that kind of
thing. Where's this? Like, one command? Now you're
sharing the namespace.
Yeah. Because the fact that it's working with
my actual host networking
through some mysterious way.
Yeah. We can ask questions about that but
I probably wouldn't understand it but maybe we
can talk about it. But I mean, there
are no limitations on the way that I
work or develop my application locally. If I
just if I don't wanna use containers or
Kubernetes at all, I mean, I could just
do go build and go run and it
can speak to Kubernetes services. Right?
I mean, that's that's pretty special. Like that's
that's not something that we're used to in
developing against remote APIs and I I really
like that. That's that's nice.
I mean and now though you're completely overshadowed
the fact that you've given me a dev
environment for sudo free for testing as well
as that's no longer important. What's important is
the network magic.
I mean how confident are we talking about
the networking stuff?
Can we dig into that a little bit?
I'm curious like
is it a am I written table? Is
it DNS resolution?
Is it intercepting all my traffic? Like, if
I open up Twitter.com,
is it gonna go through Telepresence first? Like,
can we maybe just shed a little bit
more light on that if we can?
Yeah. Definitely. So so now that you've established
that connection and the tunnel has been created,
what the Telepresence,
the local Telepresence binary, what it's doing is
it's it's adding in the DNS resolution
for the Kubernetes objects before your normal resolution.
So it's looking for, oh, he's the the
user typed in dot default or they typed
in dot namespace a. Right? And so those
things will try to get resolved first against
the cluster. And if it doesn't see that,
then it will default back to your normal
network.
And so the other thing the other thing
that Telepresence does on that connect is it
builds a it builds an IP tables,
kind
of construct and just says, oh, this is
what's available to me. And I think I
think we'll get to it eventually. But there's
a if you run Telepresence list, it'll say
everything that it sees in the current namespace.
And so those all get created on the
Telepresence Connect, which makes it very quick once
you actually want to want to curl that
service or access that service. All of those
IP table routes are are created up front.
Ah. Mhmm. Very cool.
Okay.
Let's get back to the actual doc. I'll
I'll stop driving us down little rabbit holes
here. But,
yeah, we can run get paused. It never
seems super interesting, though. Right?
Yeah. I mean, coming from the network engineering
background and then Yeah. Like, once I touched
Kubernetes, I was like, wow. There's a lot
of networking in Kubernetes.
Yeah.
Definitely is.
Okay.
Yeah. That's really cool. So DNS plus IP
tables all mixed and matched together to give
us exactly what we need from the cluster.
Okay. I've lost my place. Kubernetes
we did.
Get pods we ran.
Also now I can just browse to our
very large Java service.
And there it is.
Educorp. I like it.
Edgy's our mascot. David, know if you've seen
our little blackbird on
Telepresence, Telepresence. Name. Edgy. Edgy. Edgy the bed.
Yeah. Edgy the blackbird.
Alright. Yeah. Feel like we we we need
to update this. We really get a picture
of Edgy just on on that on that
page. Totally. Totally video. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
Front and center somewhere here. Okay. I'm AJ.
Welcome to my company. Yes.
Okay. I'll get over the magic of the
networking. Let's let's do something. So we've got
an NPM application here
that we can spin into and run.
It is worth doing, David. Just on instruction
number three above, just like nothing under the
sleeves. Right? You should see the Edgecore website
with a green title and green pod because
we're gonna change some of that stuff.
Mhmm.
Alright. Okay. Okay. Just so everyone watching along
as well, it's it's green. Yeah. Okay. So
the node application that we're potentially gonna change,
you're you're gonna ask me to change the
CSS or something that change the color of
this. Is that where we're going? Okay.
Yep.
Alright. So that's
c d
and
I need to just
n p m start.
So I don't need to do an install
first? Are we shipping node modules here? Yeah.
Okay.
So we've got a local process running on
port 3,000. Should I browse to that? Oh,
yeah. There we go.
All
the answers and I just keep going in
questions anyway.
Okay.
So we got something here where the color
is blue.
Yep.
And now we're gonna use a Telepresence
Interceptor
to
I won't guess. I'm gonna I'm gonna delegate
that to someone here.
Pierre.
Yeah. So so so so now we're at
the part where we're actually intercepting traffic. Right?
And so for if anyone if anyone listening,
used Telepresence one, we used to call this
swap deployment where there there we actually kind
of
swap the deployments out, and now we call
it an intercept because it is much more
of a routing rule
where we are intercepting traffic,
destined for a service, in this case, data
processing service. Right? And we're intercepting that traffic.
It's hitting that traffic manager in the remote
cluster, going to a sidecar, and then being
routed down into your local Telepresence,
binary where it can hit your local service.
And so and then from there, right, Telepresence
also gives you access to to the Kubernetes
API. So if your local service is reaching
out to any database connections or other services,
right, then you can it gets passed right
back through. And so that intercept is kind
of handled seamlessly as it connects your local
laptop into the rest of the cluster.
Sweet.
Alright.
So
before I run that, let's tackle a question
we got on the chat then. Naveen is
asking, does every developer get their own demo
cluster or a shared one?
I think on our conversation, what we said
is that we each get our own virtualized
Kubernetes cluster, but can we just confirm that,
I guess?
Sounds good. But
there is a limited number. That's the only
thing.
Yeah. And I think, actually, if you're on
a shared team, you you actually end up
getting added to the same cluster. If you
add with your personal GitHub account, you'd have
your own demo cluster.
So I think that's but but once you
actually start using Telepresence, you're gonna be using
it with your own cluster. And whether you
wanna share or not, that's completely up to
you.
Yeah. When I signed up, it did ask
me which of my teams I wanted to
use for for this, and I just selected
my own personal account. So I guess if
I had selected Equinix,
then anyone else at Equinix is selecting Equinix.
We'd probably get the same one. So cool.
Mhmm.
Alright. And if there's a lot of folks
jumping in, we might see, like we we
don't have a camera we we run now.
But I know, like, a few times, if
there's lots of people, like, on a on
a livestream, on a demo, like, is a
limited the finite number of the the free
clusters. But you could totally spin up Docker
desktop or something else or GKE, I've often
used. It won't stop you playing around with
demo, but you might have to come back
tomorrow and try again if you did wanna
use our one.
Yeah. Great
points. I'm assuming that because we downloaded that
KubeConfig as part of the registration part with
a master cloud. But if I was using
my regular KubeConfig, when I run Telepresence
Connect, it would just have set up that
traffic manager on my own cluster. Like, they're
completely irrelevant that my cluster came from this
place right now. Well, except for the example
services, of course. Yes. Yep.
Alright.
And then we got a comment from Lewis
who just thinks he's being funny.
Spelling color the Yukui.
Nice.
I I had this conversation with Daniel all
the time. You
know, I think I've just worked for so
many US companies. I've I've just given up
and I I know just type everything in
US English.
Okay.
Let's intercept some traffic then. So let's just
jump into here.
Why is that red?
Oh,
the paths.
So
when I ran the install Yeah. Set the
path to your that current directory. Oh, is
the banner which is here?
Yeah. I'm guessing. There we go. Okay. Yeah.
Thank you. Yeah. There we go. Alright. So
now we're setting up an intercept for data
processing service on three slightly off the bottom
of my screen there, Dave. Don't know if
that's
Yep. I do that every day.
It's because I use that like a tile
and window manager on Mac that automatically sets
the size of my windows and I keep
forgetting that the bottom of my console is
not visible. Nice.
Well, thanks for mentioning that. Otherwise, it would
have taken me like forty minutes if I
remember.
Alright. So our intercept was created.
We're not doing any SSHFS.
We can talk about that I guess in
a minute.
But now if I curl on 1 2
7 0 0 3 Thousand oh, that's the
destination. Okay.
Is this telling me that there is something
and the traffic manager of my cluster, I
redirecting traffic to the data processing service to
my local machine. Is is that
correct? Yeah. So so so what would go
to the data processing service
in your remote cluster is now being forwarded
to that that local address of 12700
on port 3000 because we specified that port
flag at the top. And so if you're
obviously using a different different service, you can
specify whichever port is running locally.
Yeah.
Mhmm.
What about
I'm trying to think now, like, you know,
say we've got a large Kubernetes cluster or
dev team or, you know, maybe six people
and we both wanna intercept the service at
the same time. Is that something that's possible
or is that a
conflict?
So so there's the difference between
authenticated
intercepts and unauthenticated intercepts.
And so when you ran if you or
if you run Telepresence status one more time,
you're gonna see that you are logged out
right now.
And and so we we could show this
again at the end, but, essentially, right, that
gets down into the difference between team collaboration
and solo collaboration. If you want to authenticate
to Ambassador Cloud, and connect to your team,
that's when you have those team features.
And so that's when you can do,
more specialized intercepts and do things like separation
on header based routing and and and more
collaborative tools.
But right now, this intercept,
because you're unauthenticated,
is just
sending all traffic down to your local machine.
It's not it's not separating anything.
Awesome. Cool.
So I'm assuming the docs are gonna tell
me to refresh edgy corp in a minute.
Oh, no. We have to make a code
change first. Right?
No. No. No. I think I think it's
that step two. You might have skipped over
it.
So after that intercept oh, yeah. Okay.
There we go. We went from green to
blue. And now it's telling me to make
a change to make it orange.
All right, let's see.
Dataprocessing@.JS.
Well, that's annoying.
Let's just close it.
Educator data
processing
that.
So this would just be me as our
developer working on my micro service locally,
making changes as we go,
and these are just gonna be
updated
in real time.
Yep.
So if we switch back there, we'll see
that node picked up the change, restarted the
service,
and
and now we can refresh.
Yeah. I think this is the kind of
feedback loop that everyone working against Kubernetes wants.
And I don't really feel that we've ever
really been there yet, but less
magic y stuff,
doing things that I don't understand is very
cool.
Just to paint the picture again to the
folks like
well, showing on the stream. So we're now,
like, going into the very large Java service.
It is calling out to the data processing
service, which is on your local machine,
which your local machine is reaching into the
cluster again to the very large data store,
getting some data. It's coming back. Data processing
service is returning that to the very large
Java service. The very large Java service is
building its web page. It's like a spring
app. So it's kinda cool as we've got,
like, requests coming in through, like, a, you
know, a front end microservice, if you like,
maybe the monolith. It's calling out to your
laptop. You're doing your thing with Telepresence,
but you can still call in. So you
got that complete chain there going on, which
I think is like it's not always always
a first glance, but it's like, hang on.
We're testing it like the user would see,
and we're calling into the cluster accessing services
that are not running on my machine.
When I first saw that, I was like,
woah. Yeah. That's pretty cool. Right?
Yeah. That is definitely very cool. I mean,
that means I could be on the call
with a very unhappy client who's telling me
to change the colors of something and just
actually do a nice thing.
That's the inspiration for the demo. I'm telling
you, I've been there. Yeah. Especially with remote
work. No. Your margin's not right. One more
pixel. No. Two more pixel. Yeah.
CSS. Right? I I I really should be
better at CSS. It's one of those things
I keep
I keep thinking I should be better at
and then every time I look at it,
I'm like, no. Not for me. Okay.
So I'm gonna try not to skip any
more stuff here and have you have to
correct me. But I think we've done this
back here. We've made a code change. We've
seen our NPM service restart locally at all
the traffic within the cluster is now seen
our new value.
Very cool.
Now we can do a Telepresence leave on
this service, which I'm assuming just means that
the traffic will no longer be routed to
my machine.
Yes. It's just gonna tear down that intercept
that we created and and disconnect the the
the
the tunnel for that. The overall tunnel will
still be up, but the connection for for
that intercept will be down.
Okay.
And now it wants me to do a
login and then do an intercept again.
Okay.
The passing is
fun for me.
That's a good bit of feedback for us,
David, actually on that one.
I I think it's just because I switched
terminal. I made it more complicated for myself
rather than anything else.
Mhmm.
Oh, so we also get a nice UI
view as well then from the the cloud
interface.
Mhmm.
Yeah. So Peter was mentioning earlier, we call
this our service catalog. So we use annotations.
So you just add annotations to your Kubernetes
services. If you actually Dave, if you pop
that to the cluster, you can do a
k or describe
service data processing service,
and you'll see the annotations with we're using
the ahr.i0
standard.
Data processing service.
Yeah.
In addition to all the things you usually
see
there
My
inability to type. Mhmm.
I might have got the oh, different context.
Of course.
Again,
me splitting my terminals gets me into touch.
If you scroll up a little bit, see
there, a atilde.io. Folks can pop along to
a tilde.io and see we've got a bunch
of sort of standardized annotations.
And you can add in, you know, links
to Slack, links to GitHub repos.
And when you pop back the service catalog,
we'll pass those annotations
into the metadata you see in the service
catalog.
Yeah. That's very cool. It's one of those
things that you don't really realize is a
problem until your team is dealing with dozens
to hundreds of micro services.
One of them is causing problems. You need
to be able to oh, there's my dog.
You have to be able to reach out
to them and work out, oh, well, who
do I even need to speak to first?
Didn't realize. That's exactly the use case. So,
yeah, we've we've, like, we've chatted a lot
of customers and they're like, when an instant,
you know, page duty fires off 3AM,
even being able to see who owns the
service and where the repo is is like
gold. Yeah? So and and then, you you
know, you don't have to use master cloud.
You can just put the a t r
dot I o annotations there and, you know,
80% of the value. But if you want
that nice UI onto it and you can
drill into the services and explore around there,
master cloud gives you that one. The community
license free for as many services as you
like for the annotations.
Nice.
Well, looks like one of our audience viewers
just ran into some trouble by deleting everything
on their cluster.
What?
Oh, no.
Unlucky no. I'm
only taking partial blame for you working while
watching this, but still.
Okay. So I like the service catalog
and a lot of values there
and
let's see what's next. So we've done the
login, we've seen the service catalog and we're
gonna run the intercept again. So what is
different from running the intercept as an unauthenticated
user versus running it as an authenticated user?
Is this where the team functionality
comes in?
Yes. And so now now once you run
this, it's going to prompt you for a
lot more information because
now
because it's running in that kind of collaborative
intercept mode, it wants to know, okay,
we're gonna create this thing called a preview
URL, which is gonna show you your application,
while using this intercept and only this intercept.
So so now this is a specialized view.
And so we're not gonna be use
we're gonna be using the the very large
Java service dot default namespace for this one.
And so so this way, right, this preview
URL is only going to show what this
application looks like while using your intercept, and
you can share that with anyone while the
main ingress is unaffected.
I mean, that sounds good.
Okay. So what should I be typing here
for our ingress IP address? Is that
gonna be This is the service that
yeah. This is the service that we want
to, render when we go to this preview
URL. So we wanna see that,
the the orange
Educorp app,
so we're using the very large Java service
in the default namespace.
Right.
Port We're gonna be using
8080,
I believe.
Should I be looking at the docs and
you're just letting me me? It's looking pretty
good so far.
I'm not you know, I'm always going to
remember as well. TLS now. Yeah.
Alright. No.
I won't ask you anymore. I'll just I'll
read the documentation like I could say.
Okay.
So now
I think we're just having return here. Right?
That's
Yep.
Okay. We're just using the default. Okay.
See, and this is this is interesting because
we're intercepting on the data processing service, but
we're rendering the very large Java service for
our preview.
And so it's showing it's showing that connection
flow of, like, this is what your application
is going to look like from the front
even though we've changed one of the middle
services
further down the stack.
Okay.
So
is this is this stalling because it's it's
now doing the thing? Like, I should just
leave that and and move on. Right? Okay.
I won't wait for that to finish. I
just wanna make sure I know what's going
on on this side. So we're not intercepting
our NPM one anymore. Does this mean this
is gonna be green again?
Or are we still intercepting? No. We don't.
We left. Right? We got a a Telepresence
leave.
We left the intercept. So this should revert
back to the default view
that it was before we did anything. And
then once that preview URL is created right?
And so so that takes a a little
bit of time because that's reaching out to
the ambassador cloud, and it's creating,
that network connection, and it's also creating, the
the this DNS
for the preview URL. So it takes a
little bit of time for all those pieces
to to kind of come together.
And so here here, we can see that
that has popped up now. The second to
last line there is our our new preview
URL.
Hstack.me.
Okay.
Right. And so now this is rendering that
orange view that you created earlier.
What?
So you're hitting the same front end Java
service, but because the preview URL injects a
header and we pass that header down through,
Telepresence is smart enough to say, when the
header is present on the preview URL, show
me the local stuff, route to the local.
And when there's no header present, pass me
through.
Right. Okay. So we
There was a disconnect in my head there.
But we ran the same intercept command we
did previously. But because were authenticated this time,
it's allowing us to have an actual ingress
preview environment that does some sort of traffic
shaping. So the only I am seeing the
orange one.
Okay. But if I refresh here,
we still got the green one. Okay. It
clicked. I got there.
Nice.
Yeah. That's that's really cool. So that's I'm
I'm assuming
anyone watching this episode can just browse to
that URL now and they're gonna see the
orange one. That's that's now meant to share
with people. They could check it out. They
can be give me the thumbs up and
go, cool. Merge it. That that's that's us.
At the very least, they do have to
log in because this is right. This is
an authenticated view, so they have to at
least log into AmbassadorCloud
so that you can see which users clicked
on this link. Right? So so so that
there is there's some
it's not just a public,
URL where anyone in the world can click
it. You have to at least authenticate to
Ambassador Cloud.
Okay.
I mean, I'm I'm gonna test that. But
I I do trust you. That's that's all
I'm saying. So
if I go to it and I say,
okay. You have to log in. You gotta
be authentic. That's a really cool feature as
well.
There's
lots to love here. That's really cool.
Alright. Let's see what's next. What more magic
am I getting today?
So yeah, we've browsed that. We saw the
green. We've seen the orange on the preview
environment. What's next? So we've got collaborating open
sessions and then the FAQs.
Cool. What should we
what should I click on next?
Is it? In fact Yeah. So so so
there's definitely, like like,
quite a few other features that Telepresence have.
Like, Intercept is the the the main the
main
operating mode of Telepresence.
But if you click on, technical reference, I
believe, is where the the rest of the
options are are located under. Right? And so,
one that we've recently we've recently we've recently
released is the the Docker for Intercepts. Daniel
was talking about that earlier, but then there
are also other other options here which can
which can kind of enhance your local development,
experience by using using containers that have volume
mounts or,
you know, passing down environment variables from your
cluster directly into,
your locally running services. So there are quite
a few different ways in which you can
enhance the Intercept experience.
Yeah. Okay. We we can run through some
of this this technical reference in a second.
I I just
I'm gonna come back to the demo we've
just done for a second because
it's just dawned on me that this is
completely different to every other tool that's trying
to solve this challenge. Ambassador
has made this a networking problem rather than
a fail sync problem. Yeah. One of the
things I see with all these dev tools
is either they're doing a container about locally
pushing it to a registry, pulling it in
the cluster, and then doing a port forward,
or they're literally syncing the entire file system
locally and to something inside of the cluster
and trying to handle this way.
This seems really different and in a really
really good way and that you've just went,
no, let's work locally
and we'll do all the traffic magic and
it definitely is traffic magic. There's no doubt.
I mean, this isn't real.
I think that's really really interesting. I don't
know why that hadn't clicked in my head
before
this session but I don't think anyone else
is solving it in this way.
And now I understand why we have a
Java engineer and a network engineer on our
call as we dissect the problem of what
Telepresence is doing. It's like this is a
networking approach to a challenge that has been
solved multitude
of other ways.
But this one just seems to work
better in my very limited experience.
Super interesting you noticed that, though, because that
that's like it's a great inference because Peter
and I are big fans of Scaffold. So
we use Scaffold quite a lot, which is
a Google tool for basically automating the build
of containers behind the scenes. So we talked
earlier about fidelity.
There's some argument that if you're using Scaffold,
syncing up either file system or or more
correctly, using Scaffold to automate the building of
the container and pushing up. So you're coding
away. You hit build.
Scaffold magically
pushes your container up behind the scenes.
Then what you're testing against in the cluster
is exactly what you're gonna deploy or very
close to it because it's built in a
container. The one thing with Telepresence is you
actually are running it typically outside of a
container locally.
Does that make sense? So that that's like
in terms of I've heard a few folks
say, oh, fidelity wise, Scaffold gives me that
high fidelity. It's like, totally get it, but
Telepresence is that gives you a faster dev
loop. And then right at the end, you
can use Scaffold. So Peter and I both
can say that. It's it's not an either
or. Right? You can use Telepresence super fast
dev loop, then you can have Scaffold in
the background uploading
to to an actual container
to give you that super high fidelity. So
all these tools plug together, but you are
spot on in terms of the file system
approach
and all the container approach versus the networking
approach.
Yeah. I think that feedback loop is what's
so important here. You know, again, I do
a lot of Rust. Like, if I'm working
on my Rust application
and doing compilations and run locally, I mean,
there has some level of hot reloading and
getting that really quick feedback loop even without
running it in Kubernetes, which is nice. But
then because it's a compiled application that runs
on a Docker container, you can get it.
At the end, I can see why I'd
want to say, you just tell it or
scaffold or something that's gonna do the build,
deploy it, and then make sure that everything
still works the way I want it to
work. So it's
not either or, it's find what works right
for you and and leverage it. That's really
cool.
Wow.
I mean, I never like networking stuff but
today I think it's it's definitely changing for
me. I'm starting to appreciate networking a lot
more.
We have a a question. Sorry.
I didn't go up here. Mhmm. Go ahead.
I'll say And and, like like, there's a
lot of times when you are working on
that local service where you just have the
external external dependencies
where
like, most of the time, it's like a
database or something where you just need to
connect to it, and that's exposed via service.
And you just want access to that stuff,
right, without creating all the network tunnels yourself.
And so just doing, a simple Telepresence Connect
and then allowing your local service to connect
to those things just makes even those processes
just so much faster, so much more seamless.
Awesome.
Okay. We we got a question from Russell
in the chat.
Is the login for the preview environment a
required feature if I'm using my own cluster?
What's the situation there? Yeah. That's a that's
a good question there. Can we can we
answer that?
So the ambassador cloud login is a requirement
for to do the collaboration features where you
want to create the preview URL or you
want to do selected intercepts,
which is which is
it it's also a requirement if you wanna
use our demo clusters,
but for separate reasons. Right? Like,
we we we giving a demo cluster, right,
we need to at least know who you
are and who's receiving it so that we
have some level of tracking. And so that's
kind of the requirement there. But for the
the segregated,
traffic,
intercepts,
those ones, we
you also wanna see who where the traffic's
going to, who's actually viewing the preview URLs,
and it gives it much more organization,
to understand how that whole process is working.
But you can use the default intercept all
traffic without having to log in to Ambassador
Cloud.
And I do know some some users really
prefer this when they're just working by themselves
early on in the process, and so they're
just like, oh, it's just my local cluster,
and I'm just wanting to intercept traffic for
myself. And then at some point later down
the development cycle, then they'll be like, okay.
Now I'm ready to start sharing things. And
then they can log in and do those
intercepts based on header routing.
Okay. I just wanna make sure I understood
that correctly. So if I'm using my own
Kubernetes clusters and I wanted to preview environments,
I would still need the ambassador cloud account,
and my team would have to be there
too.
Okay. Correct. Yes. Mhmm. If I don't
And you go. Sorry. Is it worth actually,
if you did a a kubectl get pods
all, which would just be easier, we
can show you
as this one pops
up. You actually notice in the data processing
service, there's two containers. One of those is
a sidecar.
It's actually an Envoy proxy doing the routing
under the hood. And when you log in,
we swap the sort of the basic proxy,
which routes everything with a smart proxy.
So that's kind of the the the actual,
like, technical details there. As as you do
Telepresence login, that pod that container gets swapped
out, and then you can route based on
headers and other things.
Okay. Can can we just gonna
be clear about, like, can can I do
all of this stuff with the ambassador cloud
login? Am I on Kubernetes cluster
for free, or is this where the paying
option comes in? Like, where where is the
line here?
I think I'm pretty So
is it today? Sorry.
Yeah. I think that the line currently is
at
five managed services for for Telepresence.
So so up to that point, it is
free. Okay. So people can get started then
and start using all of these really cool
features early on and playing, kicking the tires.
And then once they're as impressed as I
am, start giving you a little bit of
money back.
That that's Right. And you can use the
and you can use the intercept all feature
all you want. Right? That's because that's unauthenticated,
and so that's our open source product, and
you can use that without any limitations.
Mhmm. So everything until you do the Telepresence
login, David, like, you know, go nuts. You
can, like, do as many things as you
like there. But as soon as you do
Telepresence login, then, yeah, the five services gets
kicks in. Yeah. Yeah. I think that makes
sense. You know, if teams wanna be able
to do preview environments like that, I think
they're solving a real problem there. So if
that makes a lot of sense. And it's
it's worth noting is that's two problems we
solve. There's one is the private kind of
mode, like, you personal intercepts we call them
as in just you carve out your little
bit of the cluster because you asked that
you're on, David. Can we both be intercepting
services, the same service? Mhmm. The answer is
yes. And, like, you I could be coding,
you'd be coding, and we're not as long
as we're not mutating state in the cluster,
we're gonna be kind of isolated. Right? But
then there's also what Peter was talking about,
the shared intercept. So Peter and I could
be pairing, typically, as you mentioned in that
remote context,
I can share the preview URL. Peter can
see exactly what I'm doing, and we can
get that super fast loop going on. So
it's kind of the personal intercept versus the
shareable intercept as well.
Awesome.
Okay. So let's cover a couple of more
things, then we'll kind of wrap up our
session for today.
We've got the technical reference here, which you
said I should just pop open.
What should we take a look at? What
what explains more of the magic?
I guess what explains the magic
right? Like, if you if you click on
DNS resolution, like, I think this is where
a lot of the magic happens. Right? And
and, right, we're we're resolving a lot of
stuff based on on namespaces and what intercept
you're using. And if you are now intercepting
something in the
namespace a, right, like like, gives you access
to everything in that namespace without having to
to list it list out, specifically the whole,
service dot namespace. It allows you to just
use those service names.
And, right, that gives you much more a
much closer,
connection to what that,
experience is if you actually are in the
cluster and something is living in that namespace.
So the Telepresence list command, does that
that just lists all of the Intercepts?
That lists all the available,
services to Intercept in the the namespace that
you're in. And it also it also shows
if one of those is already being intercepted,
then it'll show, that Intercept's
information.
Okay.
Cool.
And you mentioned that the docker intercepts as
well?
Mhmm.
So Yeah. Sorry. I need to go.
Yeah. So this is a really cool one.
I think Daniel mentioned this earlier. And so
essentially, what this does is this this
will take a local
an image that you have locally.
And when you start the Intercept, it will
start that image as a container locally on
your machine and route the traffic directly into
that container.
So
one of the use cases I've done is
I I was working on a spree app
as a Ruby framework,
and the gems were just, like, super old.
It was an old version of Ruby. Sure.
I could have used r r v m,
for example, to, you know, run different versions
of Ruby. I could have done some probably
clever things with gems. But by just running
that application
in a Docker container,
I could do it by gem installs and
gem bundles in that container,
not pollute my local file system, and then
I just routed my service
to that container.
So it's kind of like, you know, encapsulating
the dev environment. And because the the the
cool feature with volume mounts, so I can
even mount my code
into that container. Right? So I can be
coding in Versus code on my local machine,
mounting the results
into the container,
getting hot reload because Spree supports hot reload.
But that hot reload, I can be hitting
from my ingress, my actual remote ingress.
Okay. That was there's a lot of concepts
there. That that that
makes sense, David. It does make sense. Yeah.
I was just trying to,
you know, keep a hold of all the
different strings. Yeah. So as was talking, I
was thinking there was a lot a lot
of concepts there. But essentially, like, particularly for
Python or or Ruby, think of RBM, think
of virtualenv.
You know, the beauty of of doing a
build even without Telepresence within a container that
folks often do multistage builds Yeah. Is you
don't pollute your local machine with all the
different gem files and so forth or or
the Python equivalents.
So the the beauty of doing with Telepresence,
you just say, hey. Intercept, but don't route
it to my local host, whatever. Routed to
my Docker container I'm spinning up as part
of this command.
I mean, it it just gives me so
much more questions.
Like
so everything in the Docker container can speak
to my Kubernetes cluster.
Yeah.
That's it. It's pretty awesome. Right?
Because my spree my spree app was calling
out to my SQL database running in the
cluster. It was calling out to another microservice
running in the cluster.
Yeah. And I was coding Versus code,
doing my code, hitting save.
How cool is that? Right?
I I I mean, even if I tried
to understand a little bit of how it
was working on my native host, I am
really confused at how it even works in
a container because it's going through a bridge
network. I'm assuming
it doesn't matter which Docker network it's on.
Does it have to be on the bridge?
What if it was on a composed network?
Like, does does any of that matter or
does it just work?
So Telepresence is actually
yeah. Yeah. Telepresence
is actually creating the container for you. So
Right. So all of those all of those
features are or like the networking features and
stuff are actually Mhmm. Hidden away from the
user.
And so so you don't actually have to
think about it. Telepresence is just looking for
that image that you have locally, and it's
going to start it with all the proper
network connections.
Okay.
That helps because I thought you were magically
changing something within my containers were already running,
and I was like, what? So okay. You
you actually orchestrate the container for me. I
just have to tell you that. Okay.
At this point, can we shout out Thomas,
Luke, Donnie, the amazing engineers that do the
work at the
source project? Lots of folks contribute. They're fantastic.
But, like, in particular, some of the networking
stuff, like, you know, wow. It's amazing that
the team would do. So, yeah, Thomas, Luke,
Donnie, massive hat tip.
Yeah. I'm gonna have to read some more
networking books.
Is there anything else we should cover before
we finish up for today? Is there anything
that we haven't talked about showing off? Anything
you wanna make sure people are familiar with?
The one final thing I was gonna mention,
Peter, is the environment variables. I know you
and I use that quite a bit. So
definitely worth, like some folks have been using
that 12 factor style, and you bake things
into your environment variables. So we can export
them to a file, either a m file
format or a JSON file format. So when
I'm using IntelliJ, there's a m dash file
plug in. So I can export all my
environment variables from the remote cluster, the the
pod I'm running in, to a file and
load that file into IntelliJ so that when
my app spins up and it looks for
the m's,
it will find them. You because the plug
in joins together the the file I've exported.
So we find the the two ones that
the two things that people often migrate to
pretty quick in the IntelliJ presence journey is
the environment variables and the volume mounts.
I hadn't thought of that. And now that
you do, it seems silly that it didn't
yeah.
Like, course, we want to build one container
image to run-in all of our environments. We
use a multitude of environment variables to configure
where the databases are, where the services are.
Some people go by convention, but I think
it's more common just to have an environment
fail. So we can actually expose those from
the remote pod to our local environment too.
Exactly. David, yeah, both like, I've got a
walk through on IntelliJ,
and Peter's got a walk through for Versus
code. So whatever you're using, and we can
and if you're using just a shell, we
can do that as well. So that's super
useful being able to export your environment variables
locally.
Alright. I guess I'll I'll throw one more
thing out, and and then, Peter, if you
have anything, we can tackle that too. But
I see our back here, and I'm scared
to click on it, but also curious to
click on it.
Go for it. Is this gonna mean does
this mean that if my pod has access
to a service account in my cluster, we're
gonna make that work locally,
or am I as my guess, widely inaccurate?
This RBAC is actually
when you do the Telepresence Connect, remember, it's
going to create that traffic manager for you
if it doesn't exist. So there are some
levels of permission that Telepresence is expecting.
And so, like, for especially for larger teams,
some some developers don't exactly have full admin
rights to the cluster to create those namespaces,
create the traffic manager. So you have to
pre deploy,
the Telepresence infrastructure,
and this kind of walks you through what
is the bare minimum RBAC procedure that you
would need in order to use Telepresence.
Okay. Perfect.
Yeah. That that makes a lot of sense.
Is there anything that you wanna look at
before we finish up here? Is there anything
we've missed?
I I I think we I think we've
covered pretty much everything. I think this is
a a good walkthrough.
Well, I think One thing I just sort
of snuck into the docs, I think it's
brand new, Peter. I think you and I
are talking to Casey about it. Is Telepresence
and Linkerd?
I I think that's that's that's hot off
the presses, folks, seeing that. So we have
a lot of requests of folks using Telepresence
with Linkerd and Istio and Console.
And Nick Jackson from HashiCorp very did a
very kind demo for us in our ambassador
fest a couple of weeks ago. I know
Casey on the team is working on the
Linkerd integration, and Istio is supported as well
even with MTLS.
So the doc's coming soon. So half the
presses. Just thought of that as you were
navigating, David.
Awesome.
Very, very cool as well. There's just I
mean,
I'll be honest, it's rare that I'm borderline
speechless with some of these demos. And I
gotta say, there's just
there's that it really has a lot to
love about the way that this just enables
me. That kind of hands off approach to
how I wanna develop my application. Like, you're
not enforcing me to adopt any
real standards or tools. You're just saying
work how you normally work using Node, Ruby,
Python, whatever. We'll handle the traffic a bit
and then things just work. And I think
that kind of hands off approach just will
resonate with a lot of people. And I
think that if you're not checking out Telepresence
yet, people should. And this is almost turned
into a shell which I feel really bad
about. But again, it's rare that I am
that impressed with the tool on the show.
Thank you for Appreciate it. Just coming on
and sharing that with us. It's very very
cool.
No. Thank you.
Is there anything Yeah. Thanks for having us.
Is there anything you wanna share before we
finish up, or will I just cut you
off now? Like, what do you want?
We'll do a shameless plug for, like, Peter
does amazing onboarding sessions, office hours as well.
So pop along to Get Ambassador website. Join
us on our Slack. You can reach out
to both of us. We're both of us
there. Cindy's does amazing work managing the community
as well. So we love to connect with
folks. We love to hear gnarly problems because
as you hinted at, David, the networking stuff
is far from simple. Right? So Peter's often
debugging
these kind of things. Get involved. We're spinning
up a summer of Kubernetes,
some training or some resources of folks that
wanna learn if they're brand new to Kubernetes.
So pop along to Slack, and we'll be
giving some more information on that in a
I think next week, of this week next
week. So we look we basically love just
chatting. We really appreciate the invite there. We
just love connecting with folks. But half the
thing with Kubernetes is just figuring out all
the tools out there. Right? So many awesome
tools that we, you know, we'd love you
to look at our tools, but that equally
scaffold other tools out there that help out.
We're happy to share our thoughts on those
as well.
Yeah. There are so many tools in the
cloud native landscape and to the point I'll
never run out of episodes to
be able to play and experiment with them.
Alright. Well, again, thank you so much for
joining me today. It's been an absolute pleasure
taking a look at Telepresence. I'm really excited
to try it out and play with it
on my own time.
I'm sure if I have any problems, she'll
be more than happy to help me, I
hope. If anyone else, reach out to people
on Twitter, leave questions in the comments. I
will do my best to forward them on
to Peter and Daniel as required. Thank you
again. Have a wonderful day, and I will
speak to you both soon. Thanks. Thanks, everyone.
Cool. Thanks, David. Thanks, David.